say good morning to Rich Eisen from the
NFL Network and the host of the RIT
sanctioned show on audience Network on
DirecTV hi rich
deeply when you back went back on ESPN
do they play a tribute video for you yes
he went back now I think they did
I think VanPelt had one that he actually
edited when I went on his show and I
said really I said Scott I can't do it
you know just not fair and and then so
he said okay let's don't do this well
your family wasn't there no no they
weren't we want and you you're just
weren't feeling a hundred percent I was
injured yeah yeah yeah I was injured my
ego was injured when I went back to the
mothership that night I hear you I hear
you so where do you want to start
I don't you tell me where do you want to
start you want to start there's lots
going on okay give me the surprise this
weekend I think the surprise this
weekend is we get the the second
consecutive season we're all wild-card
home teams win for the first time in the
history of the current playoff format I
think how about that
how's that for next animal ok that's
never happened before it happened last
year which means it stands to reason
that at some point this year we're going
to get some form of surprise but I don't
think the Titans have the horses to do
it in Kansas City and I don't think the
Falcons win in Los Angeles I look I love
the guys on the Falcons and the front
office folks and you know what happened
to them last year at the Super Bowl it's
remarkable that they made it to the
playoffs this year it really is but I
think the Rams are are a far better
offensive efficient team with a defense
that can that can keep Atlanta
offensively inefficient and I think the
Rams win that game and I'm I'm really
excited I I'm assuming we're gonna see
at least 90,000 people in that stadium
on a Saturday night with a kickoff at 5
o'clock people aren't going to have to
deal with traffic to get there there's
not really much else going on
everybody's back from from break
Saturday night we should see a nice
amount of people in that Stadium and
then you know obviously Sunday's games
maybe the bills can pull that off I'm
concerned about LeSean McCoy not being
healthy an enemy and then in the
afternoon game you know I don't see a
surprise there as well so I I think
that's it we're gonna get in the
wild-card do you look at Montrose no
honestly how do you know well because
it's too early you hit on it just you
know while I was you know on hold
listening to you guys
bandy about the the draft stuff I mean
by the time the trip right right now
there's a ton of quarterback needy teams
but somebody is gonna fill the void with
Kirk Cousins somebody's going to fill
the void with Alex Smith
somebody might you know as McLovin said
mentioned the arbitration case which I
guess is technically litigation you know
that that AJ McCarron might be free I
mean we have no idea none who might take
themselves off the board at the top of
the draft and and so right now I mean I
think I saw I saw a few friends of mine
complaining about these sorts of things
and I'm like don't don't look at it it's
way too early for that sort of stuff I
think we may sneak late at night you
made it it's like like a closet you know
Mike nobody's watching and you're
looking you're clicking on a mock draft
[Laughter]
your wife told me she check your search
list there get off the insider it's
honest it's waiting way too soon it
really really is and nobody's telling
the truth right now nobody and so you
know and and personally to answer your
poll question having heard it is no
doubt in my mind three are going to go I
really believe it I think it is what
I've is what I think Cleveland should do
Cleveland should take whoever they like
at the top it's probably going
startled from what everybody's talking
about right now and then with their
gajillion pics that were bequeathed to
them by the Moneyball administration
that's now gone they should call up Dave
gentlemen and the Giants and make them
an offer they cannot refuse and and
throw a ton of pics at them and say you
now draft forth and go and take Berkeley
and rip the knob off of Thursday night
quarterback Barkley end the story and
put them with Josh Gordon and Duke
Johnson David and Joe ku Joe Thomas
comes back healthy and and saddle up and
and see how that goes I just don't know
if the Giants would do that because
they're not gonna pick number two
overall anytime soon at least that's the
way they view things and you have to
think they wouldn't based on how
everything else is set up there when
everyone is healthy so maybe but that's
why I think they're going to take a
quarterback also and man I think jay-z
was on his hands and knees hoping that
Barkley goes there that would be great
but I believe Josh Rosen is going to be
the choice of quarterback to the Giants
and then there's the brown sitting there
at four and they can trade out I mean
they can absolutely trade out with
somebody who's really nervous that the
Jets or the Broncos are gonna take
whoever's still sitting there and and
and you'll see three quarterbacks go in
the first four picks talking to Rich
Eisen from the NFL Network a couple
other items here I'm curious your take
on how long do you think Jim Harbaugh
stays in Michigan oh boy the third rail
you went there yeah I know I think he's
staying for a while I really do you know
from the fact that he he's a guy on that
campus that despite the disappointing
results there's no other way to put it
certainly this year nobody saw a five
loss season coming that he still has the
ability to get the kids who he wants
and be the guy on campus that he wants
to be and live next door to his parents
and his kids grow up the same way that
he grew up and I think you can't
discount that you cannot discount that
and I think he has an intense will to
win at this school and it hasn't worked
out yet
and I don't think he's going anywhere I
really don't yeah I'm not sure I didn't
I didn't see him going anywhere but then
he's not going anywhere at Michigan
either
well not yet I mean he hasn't got a
quarterback yet yeah but Porter man had
it he should get a no we're back I mean
come on you you're not we're not wrong
and everybody is hoping in maize and
blue country that Shay Patterson this
kid that they got from Ole Miss is going
to get his waiver and get on the field
this year and be the guy that Harbaugh
needs and like I said I trust me I hear
it from all of my Michigan friends and
compadres
certainly when Michigan loses to Ohio
State when the backup quarterback who
hardly played a lick all year comes and
it starts winging it all over the
building in a manner that none of the
backup quarterbacks from Michigan looked
like this year and everyone's like why
don't we have one of those sitting
around and and so all that said the
defense has been spectacular and if the
offense hadn't three-and-out at him on
the field so so darn much they'd have a
much better record this year but I
believe in Harbaugh I really really do
right I got one more thing let's say
timewise I want to get this in oh yeah
is John there just six minute Julia on
the two-minute drill rather better just
do that yeah you just Berman that
segment he would is Jon Gruden overrated
or underrated hmm as a coach well I
think he is overrated for how much money
he's going to get he's getting the money
because of the fact that he was the
coach when Woodson was there and they
got tuck ruled out and he won one Super
Bowl in Tampa and didn't make the
playoffs any other years but you have to
think that this guy
has the passion has the knowledge of
your organization and also I mean and
you spoke in him and I've spoken him and
he has been sitting in his fired
Football Coaches Association bunker in
Tampa and has watched a ridiculous
amount of film and knows every possible
concept that's been tried at every level
of football for the last five plus years
I think he is knowledgeable and ready to
be a 21st century coach if you're
looking for the next Shawn McVeigh Shawn
McVeigh sounds like Jon Gruden because
he comes from the Gruden tree so why not
get the actual tree himself and overpay
for him and one question I have for you
is do you think he's calling that game
in two days yes you too yeah yeah he's
got the wild card again I don't know I I
don't know I'm still what you think they
put in somebody to do that game instead
of Gruden on Saturday
look I know him and Reid are tight but I
mean the Chiefs you don't think the
Chiefs are gonna have an issue with the
next coach the Raiders you know whatever
do their house is rich I would put Frank
Caliendo in as McDonough also he could
do that you have him do both I would
have Frank Caliendo me 200 you should
ask you should ask court hosting back if
he's available yeah well he might be
courted I think is looking for the
Monday night gig and he'll join us
coming up in energy village all right
hey thanks have a good weekend and I'll
talk to you soon about okay that's a
Rich Eisen NFL Network host and host of
the Rich Eisen show and DirecTV audience
network that follows this program coming
up top of the hour for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]